il est célèbre il est visionnaire et
pourtant il suit pas vif le holy elon
les amis je suis content parce
qu'aujourd'hui je veux pas l'être une
personnalité qui est incroyable et à la
fois que j'aime est à la fois que j'aime
je déteste c'est trop bizarre qui est
elon muscles c'est l'une des personnes
les plus riches des etats-unis sa
fortune personnelle estimée à 22
milliards d'euros il est dans le même
délire vous savez il ya jeff bezos ce
qu'est amazon us avec toutes ces
personnalités là qui ont été visionnaire
concret un truc incroyable et qui sont
devenus très riches grâce à ça et ben en
fait partie pour vous dire à quel point
c'est un ouf
à 12 ans il crée un jeu vidéo qui revend
500 $ à tous en tant pis s'il fait ça à
12 ans mais tu te grattes le crâne comme
ça jusqu'à perdre tes cheveux et avoir
une calvitie
tu te dis oh merde comment vais-je
maîtriser mon enfant à 24 ans il crée
zip tout avec son frère c'est le start
up qui vise à aider les médias notamment
les journaux à se développer sur le web
on est dans les années 95 à ce moment là
donc c'est déjà visionnaire de se dire
koulal à internet arrive ça va changer
le game de la presse on va aider les
entreprises bref vivent ça pour combien
307 millions de dollars
la même année il crée x.com qui est
l'une des premières banques en ligne
même manège en a beaucoup mais à
l'époque qu'une qu'il revend 1,5
milliard de dollars et qui plus tard pu
joindre avec une boîte pour devenir le
célèbre très pâle avec lequel tu fais
des dons à des streamer préféré e et
enfin et là en rendant le coeur du sujet
à 31 ans il crée space x parce qu'il
veut empêcher l'extinction de l'humanité
et il veut amener des humains sur mars
et veut aussi être le premier à faire du
tourisme spatial c'est à dire envoyer
des gens normaux comme nous dans
l'espace voilà pour s'amuser bref aux us
ils l'appellent tony stark parce que
tout comme tony stark il est extrêmement
riche
il fait un peu ce qu'il veut quand il a
une idée il va au bout et il se kif il a
un très concentré que bon c'est comme ça
alors là je vous ai parlé de ses débuts
mais space x c'est devenu un truc de ouf
puisque la nasa travaille avec space x
pourquoi parce qu'elle le must c'est dit
[ __ ] mais c'est relou de perles le
lanceur quand on envoie une fusée parce
qu'arriver à une certaine altitude le
lanceur se détache puisqu'il est lourd
et il sert plus à rien et il se
désintègre dans l'atmosphère donc du
coup faut le reconstruire à chaque fois
ce temps soeur et ça coûte cher
elon musk qui s'est dit mais on va faire
un lanceur qui revient ça vous l'avez vu
ça a été très médiatisé ça fait gagner
tellement d'argent que la nasa achète
sp6 des dragons ces deux petits
vaisseaux qui approvisionne les ss dans
l'espace et c'est la première fois que
dans le projet des ss la nasa fait appel
à une entreprise privée autre que elle
même il a aussi présenté récemment un
projet qui s'appelle là
falcone requête et la promesse de ce
truc là c'est que ça emmène des gens
n'importe où sur la planète en moins
d'une heure donc tu mets 30 minutes par
exemple à faire paris new york
kéba diop combien coûte le billet et
l'one en 2003 il crée t cela vous
connaissez la célèbre marque de voitures
électriques d'ailleurs hivernale chier
parce qu'en 2003 mon gars personnes
croyaient à la voiture électrique tous
les gens se foutent de sa gueule il ya
plein d'interviews qui traînent sur le
net où il se fera baisser il se fait
traîner dans la boue c'est horrible et
boss de general motors se moque de lui
etc
mais en attendant elle est là la voiture
électrique vient jouer à l'homme il a
aussi récemment créé l'hyper loupé c'est
un train qui est capable d'atteindre les
1000 km heure via quelques années il a
aussi créé n'aura link est une
entreprise qui vise à connecter le
cerveau humain à des machines pour
optimiser la performance des humains ça
s'est un peu crispé et flippant et
surtout il a inventé un truc qui l'a
jamais commercialisé j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que c'est pour l'acheter moi
même regarder ses cheveux ya vingt ans
et regardez ses cheveux maintenant et là
on sait que tu l'as le remède mais tu le
gardes pour toi petit salon pour te
sentir supérieurs à ceux qui ont une
calvitie et enfin jours il était dans
les bouchons direction l'aéroport de los
angeles et ça lui a pété les couilles et
s'est dit [ __ ] mais j'en ai marre des
bouchons si seulement il y avait un
tunnel là en dessous la route là qui
permettrait d'atteindre vite l'aéroport
il l'a fait et il a même pas attendu
l'autorisation des propriétaires des
maisons sous lesquels il ya le ya le
tunnel pour commencer à le creuser il
s'en bat les couilles tu pourra
descendre dans le tunnel avec ta voiture
tu te posera sur une plateforme qui rate
250 km/heure et qui t'amènera au bout du
tunnel
voilà il faut savoir quel homme masque
est très il veut vraiment touché il veut
vraiment avoir la barre à lui tout seul
il a beaucoup de mal à déléguer le
travail à des gens et c'est un truc
qu'on remarque souvent chez les gens
comme lui qui ont des idées très
précises sont très visionnaire etc ils
sont perfectionnistes à mort ils veulent
vraiment que tout soit comme ils le
voient je parle comme si je connaissais
au lendemain et c'est vrai j'ai mangé
avec lui hier j'étais heureuse c'est
faux il a du mal à déléguer donc il doit
gérer énormément de choses lui même donc
au bout d'un moment tu frôles un peu le
burn out voire très ample un burn-out
constamment comme ces employés
travaillent comme des brutes avec
énormément d'heures sup mais accepte ce
rythme très soutenu parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment de marquer l'histoire
les adulent complètement leur patron
elon musk donc à un petit côté secte un
peu creeping l'eau mais à côté il ya des
projets sensés et malin et des
technologies prometteuses qui nous font
rêver
donc tu es un peu le cul entre deux
chaises en voyant ça y'a pas longtemps
vous avez dû voir passer puisque c'est
devenu un mème lots de masques était
l'invité d'un célèbre broadcaster
américain sur youtube et après deux
heures d'échangés où elle au mode qui
est assez coincé il fait
transformait 10 fait un peu chier on
sent qu'il n'est pas dedans il est dans
son perso de l'oms
il commence à se détendre et le mec en
face lui propose de tirer sur sont
jointes si la californie est légale en
californie et l'oms dit ok pourquoi pas
pour tester donc y tire une halle à
téhéran le 20 et c'est devenu un [ __ ]
de même moins parce qu'il fait une
gueule après avoir tiré c'est trop drôle
et comme c'est un génie on sait pas ce
qui s'est passé dans son cerveau à ce
moment là mais mon gars il va y en avoir
des choses
bref c'est un intellectuel visionnaire
mégalo de ouf mais à côté de ça il est
vrai qu'il met en place des projets qui
sont cools et utiles et qui font même
avancer l'humanité notamment pour space
x son but c'est quand même d'aller sur
mars d'ici 2025 qui est très ambitieux
et probablement irréalisable et lui
maintient que c'est réalisable mais vous
savez à quel point c'est irréalisable
depuis vous avez vu ma vidéo sur le jeu
fait une auto promo ya pas interview qui
traîne et qui sont vraiment passionnante
et intrigante parce que c'est quand même
un vrai génie en vrai quoi qu'on dise et
du coup il ya certaines de ses réponses
qui sont mythiques et trop marrante et
en plus sa manière par les elle est
vraiment particulière fin c'est vraiment
divertissant et enrichissant leurs
gardes et des interviews de ce gars il a
par exemple déclaré calmes et 20% de
chances pour qu'on vive en fait
actuellement dans une simulation et on
verrait pas la différence entre la vraie
vie et la simulation on est un peu dans
matrix quoi imaginez-vous donc avoir la
chance de pouvoir poser une question aux
grands en tony stark et l'oms qu'est-ce
que vous poserez comme question il a
fait en 2016 une apparition au congrès
astronautique international où il
expliqué notamment tout ce qui développe
pour pouvoir voyager sur mars et à la
fin il finit par une petite foire aux
questions quoi et à des gens au lieu de
poser une question pertinente et se dire
[ __ ] j'ai avoir une réponse de fou il
s'en bat les couilles mais à un point
regardez ça
ces lots de mâche ses mots lui un truc
sur je ne sais pas moi pourrons nous
réussir à créer une atmosphère semblable
à celle de la terre sur mars
j'en sais rien mais des trucs du genre
j'ai pas la toile exact mais le loc
qu'ils durent un bisou pour lui donner
de la chance mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça là c'est mythique qui sponsorise
le congrès astronautique ou quoi là on
est où on me dit que ça détériore
l'image de la femme ont regardé bien
j'ai tout prévu à elle a masqué la shoah
peut se dit [ __ ] il a brûlé ma place
de pdg space x et les trois mois
un petit musée la tête tu sais moi des
questions j'ai répondu à des milliards
vous êtes tous qu'on va côté de moi ici
je
désolé je coupe il est évident que ça à
partir en vrille
c'est évident ah non je suis déçu mec
moi j'adore le prout et tout ce qui
tourne autour du cacao
elon musk a l'air de profondément
détesté est ce que ça veut dire que je
ne pourrai jamais être amis avec hélène
masculin sud sauvage et king regardez
combien de fois et l'aude musk a failli
pour la parole pour dire tais toi juste
toi ça te plaît ici
ici aussi et encore une fois la mecque à
l'heure actuelle faire caca sur mars est
le dernier de nos problèmes il y en a
huit cent mille autres avant c'est du
troll itron et trolleys l'oms sur le
fait qu'ils soient égocentrique c'est
pas du troll
non comment tu peux commencer une phrase
près de grains disant bon je suis un
génie comme toi et aux six lots de
masques lui-même ne s'autoproclame pas
génie qui tue pour le faire look a
aucune seconde analyse de son de ses
capacités gens en vrai ça fait de la
peine genre le mec si son rêve ultime
est où je suis sûre il a fait des pets
d'études dans la vie machin il est trop
fort scolaire en parlant mais il n'a pas
réussi à voir le travail de ses rêves et
tente comme il peut quoi en vrai en vrai
c'est triste attends je suis atterré
c'est pas comment elon musk va dévier ce
truc laval eux c'est comme ça comme
beaucoup et les caméras apprenons de
notre grand maître à tous si la pile et
pour ce il n'a même pas essayé de
contourner genre web à envoyer votre cv
et mon équipe elle verra et on reviendra
vers vous alors qu'on sait que l'équipe
regardera jamais cv qui reviendront
jamais vers lui il a dit non cash quitte
à blesser ce pauvre être humain et non
il ya un moment horrible sage lévy a pas
longtemps il y avait une scie pas
pourquoi il y avait des gens qui le
suivait chez lui avec ses enfants sa
femme et tous et sa femme elle sort un
truc horrible devant les caméras mexes
m'a mis mal à l'aise sénateurs qui date
de 2015 à l'époque il était avec talulah
riley est une actrice je crois elle
parlait du fait que quand ils sont
connus ils ont très vite emménagé
ensemble elle s'est très vite retrouvé à
vivre avec cinq enfants parce qu'il à 50
- la mosquée comment il explique les
choses devant elon musk c'est terrible
elle vient de lui apprendre
devant une caméra que ya plusieurs fois
où elle s'est dit je me barre et je
reviens plus jamais tu n'étais pas au
courant de ça tu as beau être
milliardaire et mégalo je le sais et
l'one
il a vraiment dit rêver non non et non
c'est au moment où il laissa sur son
visage
elle y repense actuellement à le faire
ça à partir à jamais revenir elle a
doute regarder ses photos
tu as beau être visionnaire faire des
voitures électriques incroyable tout ça
tu est soumis aux mêmes problèmes que
tous les autres êtres humains au il est
passé sur un light show américain je
veux voir ce qui s'est dit je veux voir
[Musique]
c'est glauque ce qui dit mec est ça qui
est glauque manga est cependant pour le
sauveur de l'humanité quoi c'est un peu
glauque séparer go il rentrait dans sa
tesla qui l'a fait lui-même et il s'est
dit [ __ ] c'est chiant je perds quatre
secondes à brancher le cap
mais qu'est ce que je pourrais faire
pour remédier à ça tous les jours il
fait des constats tse de trucs qu'il
faut perdre un peu de temps et il
investit genre des centaines d'heures
pour créer un truc pour remédier à ce
problème ça me tue et ça veut dire ce
geste-là prendre cette vidéo ne s'est
pas l'aimer ça vous a plu tout ça fou
comme on est dans une époque où tout va
vite on crée des technologies incroyable
on dépense autant d'énergie sur quelque
chose qui nous fait juste gagné 4
secondes tous les jours le bras là je
m'en suis pas remis m en cash au sein
des centres de suivre des gens comme
phénomène va y avait ce type geof darrow
lui aussi qui est un gros visionnaire
stephen hawking aussi bon je prononce
toujours mal le nom je suis désolé je
trouve ça cool de les écouter parce
qu'ils ont des projets des ambitions et
une analyse des choses qui est
fantastique et en plus leur passé leur
carrière prouve qu'ils ont eu raison sur
beaucoup de choses qu'ils avaient
anticipé des trucs très longtemps avant
que ça arrive et je trouve cela
remarquable et donc c'est toujours
intéressant voilà de suivre ces gens qui
sortent du commun même si ils ont leurs
problèmes et leurs défauts personne
n'est parfait bien évidemment mais voilà
pour notre culture à tous je trouve que
c'était bien sûr cette petite vidéo
j'espère vous avez passé un bout
c'est l'essentiel se trouve à bientôt
pour parler d'un sujet que je kiffe ou
de gens que je kiffe ou pour jouer un
truc où je sais pas ce que je me fait
kiffer je suis en roue libre
incroyable donc merci pour ça et voilà
c'est un petit merci fait que je le dise
allez on se retrouve très vite une
prochaine vidéo ou à une conférence pour
poser des questions et on lui posera les
pires nous c'est sûr à bientôt tout le
monde ciao
[Musique]
ça